[Musique]
bonjour jean claude weil et merci d'être
là vous êtes professeur d'immunologie à
l'hôpital necker enfants malades et
membre de l'académie des sciences vous
êtes un spécialiste de ce qu'on appelle
la mémoire immunitaire pourquoi certains
fabrique des anticorps pourquoi d'autres
sont protégés et ceux coville 19 pose
des questions innombrables en matière
d'immunité individuelle collective pour
faire simple qu'est ce que le système
immunitaire
alors pour faire très simple dans la
moelle osseuse tous les jours on produit
5 milliards en gros de cellules il ya 5
milliards de cellules qui sortent de la
moelle osseuse qui sont les cellules du
système immunitaire c 'est news
unitaires sont censés avoir des systèmes
de reconnaissance qui leur permet
chacune deux façons différentes de
reconnaître un objet différent un
pathogènes différents un virus
différents donc le principe c'est une
multitude de cellules dans le sang et
dans les organes lymphoïdes qui se
promènent qui circulent qu'ils font qui
scanne un peu comme des comme des
motards qui scanne constamment le
périphérique quand il reconnaît quelque
chose d'étranger cette cellule qu'il le
reconnaît puisque tout on reconnaît à 10
francs cette cellule reconnaît cet
étrange hélas hélas il est censé se met
en mouvement pour nous protéger contre
cette étrange il ya des anticorps qui
reconnaissent et il y en a certains qui
non seulement reconnaissent mais qui
attrape le corps étranger et le neutre
années qui font barrière donc il ya le
motard qui met à pv ya le motard qui met
des menottes et qui se débarrasse de la
personne qui pourrait produire des
dangers et pour le coc vie de 19 ce
nouveau virus coronavirus caisse concert
matière d'immunité sinon on est
contaminé on fabrique des anticorps qui
nous prononcer pour répondre à votre
question tout de suite s'appelle la
séroconversion dès qu'un virus rentrons
un pathogène dans l'organisme comme le
hiv comme le sida ont fait une
séroconversion pour le sida c'est comme
ça qu'on teste l'affectivité des gens
ils ont un anticorps qui a reconnu le
virus qui est rentré dans leur organisme
mais si cet anticorps ne fait pas partie
des anticorps neutralisants c'est juste
un test que ces gens ont rencontré le
s'appelle la séroconversion c'est le
test qu'on fait à monsieur x ou y en
disant voilà il ya il ya un mois vous
avez été affectés parce que vous aviez
un test positif de séroconversion ainsi
donc celle anticorps neutralisants qui
protège seul anticorps neutralisants qui
protège ses l'anticorps tout cours
spécifiques du virus qui marque la
séroconversion qui marque que vous avez
rencontré le virus c'est pas la même
chose où tous les gens qui vont
rencontrer font une séroconversion est
ce qu ils font tous des antiques en le
traduisant c'est la question et les
enfants c'est vrai que ça surprend dans
cette épidémie est ce que ils sont
immunisés parce qu'ils ont été vaccinées
où il aurait rencontré des virus
similaire dans la petite enfance c'est
une question compliquée sur les enfants
on a l'impression peut-être le récepteur
est un peu moins présent au niveau des
cellules au niveau des cellules
pulmonaires des pneus mot sites qui sont
là si la première cible du virus on a
l'impression que du fait que les enfants
sont polis vacciner quand même et qu'ils
rencontrent dans la crèche partout à
l'école énormément de pathogènes ils ont
ce qu'on appelle une immunité innée très
américaine saturn hymne il n'a été mieux
notés ils ont une immunité innée qui ne
sont pas les lymphocytes t ou b c'est
encore une autre immunité qui est très
renforcée et qui pourrait les protéger
ce qui a un peu bousculé
tous les citoyens de la planète si j'ose
dire c'est que c'est qu'on n'était pas
sûr qu'une fois on avait été contaminée
on était protégé de manière permanente
est ce qu'il y à une immunité après une
contamination du col et 19 alors les
résultats qu'on a mais on n'a pas de
résultats sur le long j'étudie nal
puisque le veulent de cette maladie
n'existe que depuis deux mois et demi on
peut pas aller plus loin ça on a des
résultats sur le co vide de 2003 on a
des résultats sur les macaques qui sont
un très bon modèle et on a l'impression
que ce virus je suis encore utiliser un
terme technique et très émue une gêne
c'est à dire qu'il déclenche une très
bonne réponse immunitaire et on
s'aperçoit que la plupart des gens ont
fait des anticorps bon de séroconversion
20 nouvelles tout le monde sait les
faire mais ils font aussi des anticorps
neutralisants donc on a l'impression n'a
pas encore regardé la mémoire t mais au
niveau des anticorps neutralisants on a
l'impression que la plus car des gens
les fonds ils font aussi des cellules la
mémoire qui pourront eux aussi produit
donc
la première réponse est oui la longévité
de cette réponse c'est sûr ça qu'on a là
nerfs nous a donné une grande à deux
équipes de l'inm dans la nôtre qu'est ce
que c'est que la longévité de cette
réponse qu'est-ce que dans six mois dans
un an dans deux ans on sera encore
protégés nobody knows comme on dira
t'elle d'immunité individuelle de chacun
d'entre nous et l'immunité de groupe on
a beaucoup entendu dire depuis le début
de l'épidémie que si à peu près la
moitié ou plus je ne sais pas de la
population était et est avait contracté
le virus elles seraient immunisés c'est
le pari qu'ont fait certains pays comme
la suède par exemple oui mais pêcheurs
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont aujourd'hui
par habitant le poussera le plus gros
taux d'infection en europe en ayant
choisi de ne pas de nom pas confiné qui
payent très cher ça ne marche pas
l'humilité le groupe limited groupe il
faut qu' il faut que 60 à 75 % des gens
sont soit aient été infectés s'appelle
heures d'immunité les angie ça peut
limiter troupeau c'est à dire que si 75%
des gens sont infectés et qu'ils ont
fait des anticorps neutralisants ça veut
dire que ça veut dire que si le virus si
le virus se balader revient ils vont
neutraliser immédiatement donc ils vont
jamais ils vont jamais le transférer
donc on peut imaginer qu'à ce taux de
protection de la population le virus ne
pourra plus se propager parce qu'il peut
pas rester plus de quelques heures chez
un individu sans être neutralisé leur
hymen forcément beaucoup plus fort boris
johnson avait décidé au début que que
l'angleterre ne confierait pas et qui
ferait la 1ère d'immunité les
épidémiologistes et les synology sol
anglais lui ont dit qu'il y aurait 350
mille morts s'ils faisaient ça donc il a
fait barrage la fée marchand
c'est ce qu'on a évité vraiment ces
chiffres la 306 on voulait écouter il ya
on est à 30 ans à peu près trente mille
morts en france si on n'avait pas fait
le confinement si on n'avait pas mis les
mesures de distanciation le masque et
tout je pense qu'on aurait dès qu'on
avait décidé qu'il fallait que les gens
s'infecte les uns les autres seraient à
combien on aurait pu avoir trois cent
mille oui c'est ce que c'est des
prévisions toujours parle aussi d
immunité croiser les buts et que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que si vous avez
rencontré un virus le corona virus
saisonniers qui produit des rhumes ou le
coronavirus de le premier de 2003 et que
vous aviez et vous avez fait une réponse
immunitaire disons avec des anticorps et
si ces anticorps reconnaît 5 également
un petit peu le nouveau virus on appelle
sa crosse réactive ils sont cons ces
limites et croisés ils reconnaissent le
premier et reconnaissent un peu le
deuxième donc il pourrait vous protéger
contre le deuxième on a l'impression que
les coronavirus saisonniers ont
peut-être des similitudes suffisante
avec le nouveau pour avoir chez
certaines personnes
créé cette protection croisée
saisonniers ou pas ce n'est pas celui
celui qui semble progressivement
maîtriser cette disparaître en sens
inverse le problème de la le problème de
la deuxième vague est ce qu'elle aura
lieu en automne est-ce qu'en général
quand on s'approche de l'été il ya une
chute des infections virales comme de la
grille pour quoi et ça repart dans une
saison plus froides on ne sait rien sur
le cockpit c'est la question de la
deuxième vague est totalement ouvert ce
qu'on ne sait rien est-ce que ce qui
frappe c'est qu'on ne sait rien depuis
le début puisque c'était à nouveau virus
deux mois et demi après on fait toujours
rien moi ça vraiment pas du tout parce
que ça fait longtemps que je fais de la
recherche et je sais toujours rien sur
le sujet sur lequel je travaille donc
pour les chercheurs de rien savoir c'est
le quotidien on a quand même appris se
tromper à tous les coups c'est le
quotidien la transmission il est très
tard ou si on a vu qu'il est 36 fois
plus en gros transmissibles que le virus
de la grippe mais il atteint pas les
chiffres de la rougeole qui lui champion
du monde puisqu'il est 15 fois plus la
mutation
l'effet l'impression qu'on a mais je
vous raconte ce que je lis et encore une
fois il faut que je revienne demain mais
l'impression qu'on a c'est que le virus
est pas très bonnes et ne mute pas
beaucoup et que sur les séquences qu'on
a fait de tous les virus qui sont que
les gens ont collecté you ready mutation
en gros et pas plus c'est ce qu'on
appelle un virus qui mute très peu ce
qui est une bonne nouvelle bonne
nouvelle saisonnalité vous disiez la
seule incertitude à sûreté vous en tant
que moi oui immunologue quelles sont les
questions quelles sont les questions qui
vous taraude le plus sur ce que vivent
19 bas il y avait une question qui me
taraude aime et qui n'apportera rien
c'était la question que les
épidémiologistes notamment les brillants
et théologie ce de pasteur avait fait
des projections à partir de ce bateau le
diamant une princesse on l'avait de 700
personnes du bateau x qu'ils étaient
infectés x qui était à symptomatique il
avait fait une projection avec une marge
d'erreur énorme en disant qu entre deux
et sept et demi pour cent de la
population française étaient infectées
sans le savoir un symptomatique mais ça
m'intrigue beaucoup ça veut dire quatre
à cinq millions de personnes auraient
été infectées sans sans le savoir en
gros en ayant tous et pendant trois
jours et tout une question qui
m'intrigue est ce que vraiment dit pas
vous semble trop important comme si je
peux pas me répond je suis incompétent
d1 symptomatique on en a pas parlé mais
soit ils soient immunisés mais comme des
enfants dont ils sont porteurs ou
malades ils ont été infectées mais non
ils n'ont pas fait de ils sont restés
chez eux où ils étaient un petit peu ils
ont un peu tousser au coin mais ils
n'ont pas fait de ils ont ils n'ont rien
déclarer sur le plan clinique et ça là
encore on ne peut pas l'expliquer à ce
stade on a la pression on l'a quand même
l'impression que les jeunes que les
jeunes notamment le personnel soignant
parce que ça c'est un très bon exemple
personnel soignant a été très affectés
dans les hôpitaux le personnel soignant
a été infecté les gens de 25 30 ans qui
ont fait ce travail fantastique
on a l'impression qu'ils ont fait très
peu ils sont restés chez eux deux
semaines y en a qui ont des caries
curieux un peu de fièvre mais ils n'ont
jamais été hospitalisé oxygénée ni en
réanimant a les pieds de réponse c'est
l'âge fait l'agent de voyage c'est le
truc majeur les gens âgés auld à 65 ans
et surtout les comorbidités
obésité maladies cardiovasculaires donc
on a quand même quelques certitudes
fatou ski en priorité non c'est pas ça
touche qui sait il ya différentes
tranches il ya 85 % de la population qui
est affecté et qui fait grippe qui peut
être qui peut durer deux trois semaines
où les gens vous racontent qu'ils ont
été très fatigué même quelquefois cinq
six semaines dans sérieuse il y avait un
article qui disait qu'ils ont peut-être
une explication pour laquelle les hommes
seraient plus affectés que les femmes
car il semble que la testostérone la
testostérone induit l'expression dur
d'un des deux récepteurs du virus donc
quand vous faites beaucoup de
testostérone da cruz est chauve par
exemple vous avez et et quand vous êtes
chauffe ça vous fait beaucoup de
testostérone nous fait beaucoup du du
récepteur dieuze donc le virus vous
affecte plus et ils ont vu ça sur les
malades qui ont le cancer de la prostate
qui ont un traitement anti tht sterone
de castration et il sent que ces gens là
sont moins susceptibles affaires
l'infection et ensuite à faire des
infections graves il ya une histoire de
hormonal est ce que cette épidémie là
nous apprend quelque chose sur une
potentielle nouvelle épidémie celle de
demain ou au contraire on restera anti
bédard mais si celle de marion parce que
là on va aller beaucoup plus loin que
comme que le cers cov de 2003 on avait
arrêté la recherche sur la vaccination
puisque
le virus ne se répandait pas au delà du
dusit d'infection là est un succès
planétaire toutes les tous les labos de
recherche du monde
en immunologie en épidémiologie en
infectiologie travaille sur ça qu'on
aura le lac st dupont nos rangs un
certain on aura un vaccin dans un an ou
18 mois et on la prendra beaucoup de
choses et je pense parce qu'on ne les a
pas aujourd'hui on en a aucun on aura
des médicaments pour soif pour soit
arrêté l'infection ou empêcher que les
gens aillent à l'hôpital où on meurt le
chercheur que vous êtes qui sait à
combien le temps de la recherche et le
temps de la science et l'on est en
décalage avec celui du soin et avec
celui d'urgence
ça le met dans quel état d'esprit ça
vous ça vous agace à vous enrage que ce
soit si long ou la sagesse du
scientifique l'emportent il faut
attendre il va falloir encore attendre
nous ce qu'on sait en tant que chercheur
et ça me fait penser à des choses de
l'actualité donc on va peut-être dont va
pas parler parce qu'on en parle trop
mais que les chercheurs
sont légitimes a tenté tout ce qu'ils
aient tous qu'il faut tenter donc on ne
peut pas reprocher un chercheur de
tenter telle piste tels médicaments
telle combinaison du comment ça fait
partie du travail prend beaucoup de
temps ces dons soient tout de suite soit
sur le long terme mais dans 95% des cas
l'équipe et les chercheurs se trompent
ça serait si on faisait une découverte
par semaine presque toujours ça marche
pas ce qu'on fait
c'est pas grave on passe à autre chose
c'est tout c'est comme ça on a le bon on
a le droit de tenter tout le temps des
choses et je crois que pour la pour la
recherche fondamentale comme la nôtre on
sait qu'il faudra six mois un an pour
comprendre qu'est ce que c'est que là la
réponse immune la mémoire imu un an un
an et demi pour les médicaments les gens
tendent tous dans tous les sens quand ça
marche pas ça marche pas on arrête merci
beaucoup faisant partie d'un peuple
[Musique]